wie könnte unsere welt in zehn 20 30
oder 100 jahren aussehen klicks um
science-fiction hat ja eine kooperation
mit technology und deren redaktion hatte
in diesem sommer schon zum fünften mal
junge leute gekürt deren ideen und
erfindungen schon in naher zukunft unser
leben hochwahrscheinlich maßgeblich
prägen werden wie sie die zukunft also
aus herzlich willkommen bei klick zum
science fiction am ende gibt es übrigens
ein gratis exemplar der zeitschrift
technology review platz fünf internet
durch glasfaserverbindungen deluxe
gerettet glasfaserverbindung haben ein
riesiges potenzial und können uns
demnächst auf allen endgeräten videos in
kinoqualität liefern oder operation
roboter ermöglichen die chirurgen über
das internet steuern
doch die große herausforderung bei dem
konzept der glasfaserverbindung bestand
bislang aus physikalischen hindernissen
beispielsweise ist der frequenzbereich
des lichts in dem die daten über die
fasern verschickt werden begrenzt und
der bereich der nutzbaren frequenzen
geht stück für stück zur neige eine
katastrophale situation für die
fernverbindungen die über die
unterseekabel zwischen den kontinenten
laufen denn sie werden schon sehr bald
hoffnungslos überlastet sein
der elektroingenieur von teile aus
stuttgart hat eine großartige idee gab
glasfaserverbindung zu optimieren er hat
auf dem dilemma herum gedacht dass es
eben nicht einfach die lösung sein kann
mehr bits pro sekunde durch die
glasfaser zu schicken dazu lädt dafür
müsste man die intensität der impulse
verstärken das aber führt dazu dass die
lichtsignale sich auf nichtlineare weise
verzerrt
bekannt ist dieses problem auch als
sogenanntes shannon limit das beschreibt
inwieweit eine fehlerfreie
datenübertragung möglich ist und zwar in
abhängigkeit von bandbreite und dem
signal rausch verhältnis jetzt aber
endlich zu lesen lösungsansatz der
dieses limit umgeht der ingenieur hat
ein verfahren entwickelt das die zu
erwartenden verzerrung berechnet und die
signale so formt dass die steuereffekte
ausgeglichen werden tests zeigen dass
die kapazität der glasfasern so um 50
prozent gesteigert werden
ja und damit nicht genug lee hat
außerdem ein verfahren entwickelt
mit dem die maximale datenrate in einer
frequenz kanal von 40 achtung auf 256
kilobit pro sekunde gesteigert wird und
dass tatsächlich das ist weltrekord in
den nächsten sieben jahren will die
kapazität von glasfasern um das
zehnfache steigern und das ohne
zusätzliche kosten platz vier
menschenleben retten blutvergiftung
durchgehend analyse auf die spur kommen
blutvergiftungen sind lebensgefährlich
pilze gifte bakterien dringend über eine
verletzung in den blutkreislauf an und
die entzündungsreaktion die kann dann zu
organversagen für 27 millionen menschen
sind jedes jahr weltweit betroffen
ein drittel davon stirbt der
bioinformatiker philip stephens hat eine
idee entwickelt menschenleben zu retten
dazu hat er eine software ins leben
gerufen die nach bruchstücken der
erreger dna im blut der patienten und
patientinnen sucht damit wird dann nicht
nur ganz klar diagnostiziert ob ein
mensch betroffen ist sondern auch
welcher keinem der auslöser ist
gegenmaßnahmen wie eine antibiotikum
gabe können dann zeitnah erfolgen
mittlerweile werden schon erste
klinische studie und vorbereitet und
stevens ist zuversichtlich die sätze es
ist nur der anfang
auch anderen infektionskrankheiten
könnte man nämlich so demnächst auf die
schliche kommen platz drei glas aus dem
drucker fredericks vom institute of
technology in karlsruhe hat ein material
entwickelt das jeweils die besten
eigenschaften von glas bzw kunststoff
vereint eine supersache beispielsweise
für die linsen von handykameras ihn
bestehen derzeit aus kunststoff dabei
wäre quarzglas deutlich besser denn es
ist bei temperaturschwankungen
formstabil hoch transparent und
knallhart doch der entscheidende
nachteil der werkstoff wird erst bei
2000 grad celsius flüssig was es
unmöglich macht große mengen an winzigen
glas erzeugnissen günstig herzustellen
das neu entwickelte material hat klar
summe genannt es lässt sich verarbeiten
wie kunststoff hat aber dennoch die
idealen eigenschaften von glas dazu kurz
das ist ein kunststoff in dem ein hoher
anteil an glas nanopartikeln eingelagert
ist bestrahlt man das material mit licht
verbinden sich die kunststoff moleküle
und werden fest
die flüssigkeit wird in handelsüblichen
3d stereo lithografie druckern verwendet
der kunststoff verdampft dann bei rund
600 grad in einem hochtemperatur ofen
und die glas nanopartikel werden
versöhnt hat also sie verschmelzen
die form des bauteils bleibt erhalten es
wird jedoch dabei ein wenig kleiner mit
seinem startup will kurz seine
technologie jetzt auf den markt bringen
platz zwei effektivere therapien im
kampf gegen den krebs
der therapeutische nutzen von
chemotherapeutika ist begrenzt die
nebenwirkung sind gravierend denn die
wirkstoffe greifen nicht nur die
krebszellen sondern auch gesundes gewebe
an dominik schumacher hat eine idee
entwickelt bei der die entsprechenden
wirkstoffe tatsächlich erst dann
aktiviert werden wenn sie auch wirklich
auf eine krebszelle treffen
so werden die gesunden zellen nämlich
geschont und ausgespart antrieb basiert
auf dem schon existierenden sogenannten
antibody drug com uk csi verfahren
verbindung zwischen antikörpern und
medikamenten die eigentlich nur die
krebszellen angreifen die er selbst aber
noch einmal optimiert hat denn bislang
gab es ein großes problem mit diesen adc
die verbindung zwischen antikörper und
wirkstoff waren viel zu instabil
schumacher setzt ein bestimmtes enzym
namens too bulin tyrosin liga sein was
besonders stabile adc erzeugt dazu der
forscher damit wird verhindert dass der
wirkstoff im blutkreislauf des patienten
freigesetzt wird mit seinem startup will
schumacher diese technologie jetzt auf
den markt bringen und damit dem krebs
den kampf ansagen platz eins
vernünftiges und lukratives recycling
von elektroschrott bei der aufarbeitung
und dem recycling von elektroschrott
werden staubsauger oder it geräte oder
oder in super kleine stücke
zerschreddert in ein granulat und aus
diesem granulat werden aluminium kupfer
und eisen abgeschieden das problem das
ist längst nicht alles 20 bis 25 prozent
bleiben derzeit über einiges davon geht
dann unter tage weil es mit schadstoffen
belastet ist und in einigen ländern der
welt landet es immer noch und das ist
sehr traurig auf gewöhnlichen deponie
der fraunhofer-forscher peter hense hat
ein verfahren entwickelt das deutlich
sinnvoller und lukrativer ist bei dem so
genannten verfahren wird aus den
schredder rückständen ein metall
konzentrat gewonnen
das enthält dann auch noch silber kupfer
gold oder platin gruppen metalle auch
die rückgewinnung versorgungs kritische
high tech metalle wie tantal oder indium
wird so möglich gemacht chlorhaltige
abfälle werden genutzt um das sehr
seltene metall indium aus
flachbildschirm oder monitoren zu
recyceln
der kunststoff dagegen wird zu einer art
diesel oder gas was vor ort verbrannt
wird um den prozess mit energie zu
versorgen
das öl kann dann genutzt werden um wärme
oder elektrische energie zu gewinnen
konkret basiert das verfahren auf einem
wärmeaustauscher in schneckenform der
mit hilfe eines metallischen wärme
fluids die schredder rückstände auf
ungefähr 650 grad celsius erhitzt das
passiert in mehreren stufen unter
sauerstoff abschluss dadurch wird der
kunststoff in kurze kohlenstoff ketten
zerlegt ohne eben zu verbrennen weil es
kein sauerstoff gibt zudem entstehen wie
gesagt gas und öl bei den schadstoffen
wie etwa den prämierten und chlorierten
voran und dioxin lag das hauptaugenmerk
von peter hense sie werden in diesem
verfahren auf konzentrationen kommen die
unter den gesetzlichen grenzwerten
liegen hensels angaben zufolge sogar zum
teil sogar unter der nachweisgrenze und
auch wirtschaftlich gesehen soll das
ganze sinn machen das verfahren
produziert ein metall konzentrat dass
sich für 800 bis 2600 euro pro tonne an
kupferhütten verkaufen lässt vielen dank
an technology review in zusammenarbeit
mit der redaktion dieser wirklich
absolut coolen zeitschrift ist dieses
video entstanden
und exklusiv für klicks um zuschauer
habe ich jetzt ein geschenk
ihr bekommt nämlich eine ausgabe gratis
wenn ihr auf diesen link liegt das lohnt
sich richtig das sind noch mehr hammer
themen drin
ja und da drunter geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken smarthome die
zukunft des lebens bis dann bleibt dran